the derivative of cos inverse is very
familiar what is it it's negative 1 on
the square root of 1 minus x squared now
at this point you like hold on a minute
wait a second this was doing this to me
again I played a trick on you did you
notice you already worked out this
derivative you already worked it out cuz
what does cause it must apply it looks
like this does it not now tell me well
we're interested in a derivative which
tells you about gradient gradient ok now
the grading of this graph if I move it
somewhere else for instance if I move it
here or here or here it's still the same
derivative right it's exactly the same
in fact you already worked out what it
is that's negative case the one we
exclude it over here ok so that's one of
the ways which I always found it
frustrating than like our man a
mathematician trying to make things so
that they are very easy to mix up with
each other right because I mixed up the
plus or minus case right and answer is
no there is just symmetry here that
can't be ignored right so that's an easy
way for you to think about which one's
the positive negative well which one is
increasing which one is decreasing okay
now similar kind of thing to notice on
tan inverse tan inverse it's its
derivative doesn't have a square root of
why not think about it why doesn't it
because of the identity that you use not
requiring a square root involved right
in order to get your X's and Y's or
figured out ok so these 1 plus 1 plus x
squared so things to notice about this
not only is there no square root right
but also there's no value you can stick
into this node value is to get it is
that makes this derivative break right
because the derivative of 10
verse is a very non fussy eater right
you can throw anything after you why is
that because tan inverse exists for all
real values of x right that's why its
corresponding derivative 1 plus x
squared that exists for all your values
of x is that make sense when your
regional function is not fussy a
derivative won't be end up okay so there
you go that gives you an idea one more
thing we might do now that you know all
of the driven is if you wanted to you
could do something like this call it you
in mathematics the question is never
isn't necessary no question is will we
gain any understanding out of here this
for a different point of view now what
are you expecting to get what are you
expecting it you've graphed this then
you already know what it looks like why
are you expecting well then rather
depends doesn't it on what domain you're
interested in okay let's just see what
happens you tell me what should I write
differentiate the inside no one
you differentiate the outside just say
in verse which gives you this yes times
1 over the square root of what 1 minus
the inside function sine square yes hold
on 15 stop stop is this really the case
I question this line before I go any
further I'm just going to keep going you
told me this was cos square which is
cause right so I'm getting cos x times
one on cause because the square root is
always positive that gives me one what
happened that wasn't what you told me to
each backs haha so we use this sine
inverse derivative but this derivative
has a restriction built into it but we
already we labor over the fact that this
is not restricted right so seeing as
this is not restricted this is not
restricted either this is still a
plus/minus so this is still plus minus
so this is a plus minus depending on
your domain ok good cool all right